you
[Music]
welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we're hosting webinars
every Tuesday my name is Micah Trotsky
and then when joked and today we'll be
talking about network security controls
for your containers you can ask
questions anytime on the platform and we
have Googlers on standby to answer them
so let's get started so today we'll be
covering first container network
security 101 how does that even how is
it different for you to secure your
container network than for your VM
traditional VM network containers
network security controls so how you can
make sure that your network resources
are accessed by authorized parties and
we'll dive deep into the controls that
are available for you on gke and then
visibility how you can monitor the
traffic that flows between different
containers in your environment
lastly we'll leave some time for Q&A so
container network security 101 first how
is securing containers and Canadian
networking different than VMs well
containers have a different surface of
attack than virtual machines do they
they are meant to be smaller meant to be
you know reduced bloat images that you
deploy for networking what that means is
that a lot of the plugins and things
like that should be smaller right it
doesn't doesn't it's the same idea
you're gonna want to reduce the amount
of things that you add to your container
images so you have fewer chance of
vulnerabilities in those containers
service isolation services have
containers and orchestrators like
kubernetes have some built-in ways for
you to isolate your different services
and resources including storage
permissioning networking etc one of
those things are firewalls and in
network policies Carini's has built in
concepts to let you to let you have
isolation with firewalls between
different containers in your network
permissioning access control and network
resources and other resources allow
delegation of administrative functions
without having potential compromise or
other issues so you can have a
separation of duties between who sets up
your containers and your networking
versus who has to use those containers
and that networking and nicely
lastly lifecycle containers on average
have a very short life span Cystic
estimates that 95% of containers live
for less than a week what that means
from an attacker point of view is that
it's you know harder for someone to
persist in your network but if they do
persist in your network you might and
then you restart that container redeploy
that container you might not have any
forensics - as
what happened after the fact this
doesn't really impact networking but
might impact how you how you put in
place certain controls so what are the
different surface of attacks we need to
be worried about the first one as Maya
mentioned his network resources you
might not want as an organization you
might not want critical network
resources like your LB rules your
firewalls your pairings to be under the
control of every single project admin
you might want to have them be under the
control our be set up by network and
security admins second private
addressing you might want to ensure that
your entire deployment including your
nodes your pods etc are within the
secure boundaries of your V PC moreover
you might want to ensure that your
control plane is also I isolated from
unauthorized access over the Internet
third service communication another
thing to ensure or another surface area
of attack can potentially be social
service communication so you might want
to ensure or control the access of which
services can talk to which other
services through something like Network
policy which enables you to set up those
rules fourth manage services access when
you're using a kubernetes or a GK
deployment chances are you're also using
a host of GCP managed services like
continued registry or data proc or
bakery and several others another thing
to ensure or another surface area of
attack to cover is the communication
between your GK deployments and your
managed services so looking at network
security over all this the image in
front of you will tell you where all
those pieces fit in so first and
foremost your deployments are within a
signal secure boundaries of a vbt
network you have your private clusters
which have no public IPS on the nodes
and which can securely communicate to
other clusters over VPC firewalls
moreover you have the PC service
controls to control access to other
managed services like container registry
and bigquery on the l7 internet facing
side you have cloud armor and identity
aware proxy set up with your global
balancer to control access to your gk
deployments and you use master
authorized networks in your gk clusters
to control unauthorized access to your
master to your kubernetes master
similarly you have network policy if we
drill down within a single cluster first
set up for service to service
communication so let's talk about the
network security controls in detail the
first the first thing we are going to
talk about is share v pc so i spoke
about how as an organization you want to
delegate administrative responsibilities
to your project admins but you don't
want your critical network resources to
be dealt by them but you want them to be
under the network and security and
shared VPC enables you to do that
private clusters help you achieve
network segmentation by ensuring that
your nodes are within the secure
boundaries of your EPC and use only RFC
1918 addresses and moreover for private
clusters another thing you can
potentially put in place is master
authorized networks a master authorized
networks put puts in an IP white list on
your kubernetes or GK master and ensures
that it's blocked from unauthorized
access over the Internet
network policy helps you achieve service
to service helps you segment micro
services by restricting which services
can talk to which other services now
let's talk in more detail about each of
those so I spoke briefly about share V
PC and share maybe C is what enables you
to map your organizational topology to
your network topology so let's say you
have an infra team and an Apps team and
several apps team in your organization
you want the apps team project admins to
be able to create update delete and
manage those clusters seamlessly but you
might not want them to set up things
like org level firewalls or you know you
might not want them to set up LB rules
and a host of other such things so in
order to have that model be present you
you can use share V PC so you put your
infrastructure project in your host
you're said BBC in your host project and
you have a shared we PC within that host
project within the shared we PC you add
a host of service projects which
actually have your apt specific clusters
this way you get security and separation
of rules your network and security
admins set up the firewalls and not the
project admins you get sharing of common
resources because if for example you
have a pool of IP addresses that you
want to share across that shared VPC
network you can actually achieve that
you get isolation of data in multi
tenant workloads by isolating the
different projects and the subnets and
all you also get more granular billing
because you can actually separate out
the projects so share PPC deep dive as I
mentioned there is a host project and
within the host project there's a shared
VPC Network the shared VPC network
itself is divided can be divided into a
bunch of subnets and then you give your
app projects permissions over the single
a single subnet so you get your you give
them the compute dot network user
permission over a single subnet and this
way your app teams can actually create
manage and delete clusters but if you
want to set up firewalls let's say then
you have to go to the network admin you
so you talk to the network admin and or
and you ask them to set up firewalls for
you in the shared VPC network this way
you get as I mentioned earlier I
separation and isolation of rules while
still enabling you to share common
resources throughout your organization
moving on to the second one which is
private deployments with private
clusters private clusters take your
nodes off the public internet by
removing all those all the public IP s
we used to initially require the public
eye piece in order to be community in
order to communicate with your educating
master but that is no longer a
requirement with advancements in our
appearing capabilities so now for your
private clusters the communication
between your master and your nodes is
completely private and within your VPC
and moreover if you create a private
cluster by default we enable master
authorize network which default denies
all unauthorized
says to your to your decaying master
private clusters help you with simplify
the scope of some of the compliance
requirements that you might have for
your applications as I said about master
authorized networks by default if you
create a private cluster we enable
master authorized Network and we highly
recommend using master authorized
Network along with your private cluster
if you want to enable certain IP ranges
on your own premises you have access to
your GK master you can set up a master
authorized network with some certain
site or ranges that you want to
whitelist over your master this way you
have a private cluster and you have
block unauthorized access and you allow
only authorized IP addresses to access
it a little brief note about shared VPC
so you cannot move from a non shared VPC
to a shared vpz you cannot update an
existing cluster in a non share vbc
model to a shared VPC model similarly
you cannot update a cluster that is not
private to become private but you can
add master authorized network to an
existing cluster so you might want to
start off with shared VPC model first of
all then move on to creating private
clusters and then updating removing
master authorized networks looking
deeper into how to enable it in the UI
you clearly see a network security space
where you can enable a private cluster
and the moment you enable private
cluster you see that we have enabled
master authorized network where it says
access master using the external IP
address so you you can actually add
authorized networks right underneath it
if you want to over their network policy
so I've already mentioned how as you
develop a microservices architecture for
your applications you might want to
restrict which services can talk to
which other services earlier when in vm
based architectures how services were
isolated were usually with a firewall or
network layer firewall which was very
typically a very physical device on the
VM so a service was isolated
let's say in a few VMs which could only
talk to certain other Williams but that
model doesn't work when it comes to
containers as Maya mentioned earlier
that the container lifecycle is very
short and they're very dynamic so they
keep on coming and going so the new way
to actually control or restrict service
to service communication and set access
controls on which service can talk to
which other service you want to use
network policies network policies enable
you to ensure that let's say you have a
compromised front end service if you
have a compromised front end you might
want to ensure that something as
critical as your payment's back-end
poles are not compromised so this way
you can set up network policy rules for
your services so for example in this in
this object in this policy here you have
ingress and egress rules which can work
on the basis of POD selector labels that
you might have on your services or you
can work on the basis of IP address
rules so you can add address ranges that
have access or don't have access to your
services network policy is enforced in
nearly real-time and scales to scales
with your G K clusters seamlessly
ingress integrations now another very
critical aspect of your deployment is
ingress and the communication to the
Internet and how ingress actually sets
up your load balancer so we will talk
about a host of features you have
available to yourself to integrate with
ingress the first one is identity aware
proxy you can enable your employees to
work from untrusted networks without the
user without the need of a VPN and
moreover you can give them more granular
access than an all-or-nothing access
which is typical of VPN connections
cloud armor is our defense against a
distributed denial of service attacks
engine you definitely want to have some
sort of DDoS protection built in into
your load balancer or some sort of sort
of DDoS protection enabled for your
deployments to prevent from all sorts of
edge attacks from malicious actors
multiple TLS certificates support so
this is to enable multiple ssl
certificates or multiple TLS
certificates for your deployments for
every single domain that you own so the
first one identity aware proxy which
enables you I am based access control on
poor application basis identity aware
proxy acts as a central authorization
layer for all your applications and you
can control which who gets access to on
an application-level basis to which all
which all internal apps you might have
instead of relying on network level
firewalls or VPN as I had mentioned
earlier you see on the slide here how to
actually integrate with IP so you the
first thing you define is a back-end
config object we introduced this concept
of a back-end config object so that we
could have more GCP specific annotations
for your GAE clusters the first thing
you do is define the backend config
object and then within the spec you set
your IP settings the actual client you
have to go ahead and create as part of
your IP setup flow and then you just
come back here and add your secret name
once you generate the secret as well and
then once you've generated your back in
once you've created your back in config
object you go back to your service
definition and you actually add a link
within annotations for the service to
your back-end config object as mentioned
here as I mentioned IEP performs
authentication and authorization on per
application level and this helps you
basically let your employees work from
anywhere on untrusted networks cloud
armor this is our DDoS protection engine
besides the dos attacks it has
protections built in against also host
of different attacks such as SQL
injection XD XSS attacks currently it
supports IP blacklist whitelist and also
it it has a custom rules language which
you can use to have custom policies
custom rules set up for your
applications if you look here you
basically have to set up again in a very
similar way to I ap you sir
back in config object and you define
your security policy within your spec
the security policy that you define here
most of the configuration is actually a
part of your regular cloud armor set up
and what you define here is only the
linkage between the name of your
security policy that you define in your
cloud armor setup and similarly once you
define your back-end config object you
have to add a link back to your service
definition this way this was done on
purpose because we wanted to simplify
configuration for your cloud armor
security policies and have them be done
in one single place with cloud armor and
then just add linkages wherever possible
visibility so one of the most important
things when we talk about security
network security is being able to see
what is going on in your network and get
to know if there's any any malicious
actors trying to gain advantage of their
network so one of the most important
things that we have for for you would be
we receive so logs that can actually
give you raw logs of all the flows
within your network VPC flow logs are
aggregated every five seconds so nearly
real-time and they are not agent based
for for GTA V PC flow logs moreover
cover all the flows within your network
whether it's to or from the internet
whether it's between services in your V
PC whether it's to manage services or
whether it's from your on-premises
moreover it includes both egress and
ingress and it can be enabled at the
granularity of a subnet it also covers
TCP UDP flows and it also covers a host
of features like share V PC
BBC peirong etc a typical flow log
record includes bytes in for our tt's
moreover it has several annotations that
we very useful such as VPC annotations
which instance which with sub Network
etc and which region which zone and
other geo annotations
it can be used for security analysis
Network forensics moreover
you can also export the raw VPC flow
logs in a secure manner using things
like cloud pub/sub to stand driver
logging or bigquery or any other engine
of your choosing
to visualize visualize them and track
them so here we see how to actually
enable vbc flow logs as you can see when
you're trying to create a subnet or when
you're trying to edit a subnet within a
VPC Network you get the option of
turning on VPC flow logs so now we move
into the demo so I think I mentioned
earlier while introducing shared VPC
that what is typical of organizations is
you have infra or platform teams and
then you have app teams the app teams
are the ones that actually create an
application that talks to users over the
Internet and the infra team is the
bottom there with sets of things like
firewalls or permissions and etc so
typically what you want is the apps team
to create clusters such that they can
talk to the internet or just be able to
manage those customers and the infra
team to set up all those firewalls and
other rules so here my setup would
include an organization which has a host
project called infra team and a service
project called apps team the host
project has a Sherri PC network called
shared net and it has one subnet called
Apps tier so the way I set up my project
here is my clusters for Apps team would
be within the sub Network apps tier and
my hosts project has already set up
firewalls and everything else for me to
be able to communicate over the Internet
let's see now so here you see details
about the shared VPC network in infra
team project so this is my these are my
shared subnets and permissions and as
you can see here basically a host of
service projects have permissions
compute
network user permissions and these are
the only permissions that they have
which means my service projects in my in
my my service project robot accounts can
actually use my apps your subnet without
needing to have edit or modify
permissions you can see here that the
only projects I have attached to my
account are my apps team projects now
let's move on to actually calling so if
I actually if I move here so you see
here now that I have to create a two
clusters in my apps team project one is
a private cluster which can host a host
of back-end services which don't need to
be on the public internet and my hello
cluster has the most amazing app ever
built which is saying hello to Google
cloud webinar viewers so now I will just
try to call my application again and
again and here you will see here you see
a host of VPC flow logs so what I did
earlier was I had enabled VPC flow log
on the App Store and my and my default
subnet and how I actually get to or
export my vbc flow logs is through stag
driver logging so if I come here and I
drill down within my GCC GCP sub Network
and filter by only VPC flow logs I get
to all these VPC flow logs do note that
every single one of these records even
if I don't make any requests you will
actually see a lot of flow logs being
generated because we try to cover every
single flow in your network even if you
are not getting requests from the
Internet and if we try to drill down
here for a single for a single request
you actually see the different
annotations that are there you see the
the VPC name the sub network name the
project name you see the source location
and you see the connection information
if you see this is the internal IP
address of my of my node and similarly
that is also an IP address of the master
you see this for example this record is
the communication between the node and
the master similarly you can use this
particular bar to filter on the basis of
a specific port or if you're if I'm
making requests from my host I can
filter from my IP address or something
to actually see the communication
between the load balancer and my servers
so this way you can get to flow logs for
your application
moving back so that was an awesome demo
today hopefully you learned a lot about
container network security and some of
the controls that we have on gke to help
you secure your network but talking
about container security a bit more
broadly you know why why would you start
using containers to help you achieve
better security and these is that even
possible well as we already mentioned
containers are short-lived and
frequently redeployed so you can
actually be constantly patching and
updating your environment right you can
apply a patch in your registry that then
gets gradually rolled out as you would
roll out any other change in your
environment that leads to a very
different model for how you manage
patching rather than having maintenance
downtime and windows and what you have
to do that kind of work
containers are immutable so you can
ensure that your environment doesn't
change what that means is that if a
designer does change a production you
know something's gone wrong and you can
then kill that container and redeploy it
as needed it also means that you have
content addressability so you know
exactly what's been deployed in your
environment and then if something does
change if you know if there's new
vulnerability discovered for example you
can compare what you deployed to to the
vulnerability rather than having to scan
your production environment directly
that saves you a lot of time with the
control plane being managed in a
container orchestration system you can
actually secure the communications that
happen between the control plane and the
services and between your services so in
addition to what my John was just
describing today around you network
policy using BBC flow logs etc how your
control plane to node communication
happens is is secured and can be can use
you know encryption authentication etc
and then lastly in terms of container
security here good security defaults are
one-line changes right you can follow a
lot of best practices like by
implementing Linux changes things like
enabling set comp or in gke turning on
master authorized networks
it's a single change for you and your
team to get that that best practice now
what that means overall is that running
containers allows you to adopt a
fundamentally different security model
you are constantly patching you are
constantly deploying it is that kind of
dev SEC ops or continuous security that
people talk about but you don't
necessarily lose a lot of control you
have from before they're just different
from how you were doing it with VMs now
on GK specifically obviously we're we
think we have great security great
network security here so GK provides
best practices with security by default
there's always gonna be a plural
hardening for you to do but more and
more things are being built into the
platform by default you can check out
our hardening guide online for what we
recommend you do beyond beyond what's
already there things like network policy
being being shipped as part of GK core
has been true since for for several
versions now the criminals dashboard is
disabled lots of other security features
built in GK patches you to the latest
version automatically so the control
plan is patched for you by our SRE team
and then nodes you can set to auto
upgrade to get patches as well this
keeps you up to date with not only the
latest feature releases including new
security features the new networking
features the latest security patches if
you've been following the news we had a
major security vulnerability that was
that announced yesterday it's already
fashion gke we had one a few weeks ago
that affected network policy it's
already patched in gke so you get that
benefit by having a managed solution and
GK provides the best of Google Cloud
security features so their integrations
with things like I am audit logging but
also with shared VPC with EPC flow Logs
with IEP with lots of other things that
you might want to use to improve your
overall security and network security
story there's a few links for you here
to learn we're going to look more
including on overview of our network for
for containers and container security
but please stay tuned for a live Q&A and
we'll be back in less than a minute
you
awesome we're back with the
the audience so Manjot does the first
one here does network policy work to
restrict pod to pod traffic within a
node so you start you can set up network
policy to restrict which services can
talk to much other services on the basis
of an acceptable app select errs or IP
adresses and if that condition holds
true then you can restrict got to port
traffic whether it's what they know node
or between nodes do I need to do
anything special to set it up between
nodes or does just kind of work they
don't just work through the policy agent
okay the next question here do I need to
use master authorize networks to use
private clusters the answer is no you
can definitely use master authorize
network in isolation with or without
using private clusters we highly
recommend using master authorize
networks with private clusters in fact
another recommendation I will make is
you should probably think of making
private clusters the default for all
your classes unless internet access is
required it's a good idea the next one
do private clusters have private IP
addresses for the control plane so there
is a private IP address and a public IP
address both on the master the private
IP address as I mentioned is used to
communicate privately with the nodes but
there is a public IP address which we
manage and that we use for our internal
management purposes currently how does
sto work with kubernetes and what does
it protect Sto definitely adds a few
more features on top of kubernetes for
more defense-in-depth protection for
example one of the things that
kubernetes sorry sto offers is mutual t
@ s between services so your services
can actually authenticate and authorize
while communicating with other services
so it's tos for like services service
but then not for a pata pod for example
yes ok and then what's the recommended
configuration if I want to peer my on
Prem network to gke so we have a host of
different options under a cloud
interconnect depending on what kind of
reliability you want how much what kind
of like how much reliable you want the
connection to be and things like that
you can choose a host of different
products under cloud
such as VPN dedicated interconnect etc
and I would set that up with a V PC or
something like yes yes okay cool so I
think that's that's a wrap for us please
stay tuned for the next session
CET V Google cloud networking 103
securing your network thank you